thanks everyone I want to thank the
organizers for inviting me to this
workshop it's been really interesting
this is joint work with XI Jung Yong
king and Jin Yu and it's gonna have a
slightly different flavor from a lot of
the talks we've seen so far though there
will be a little bit of lower bounds in
it it's really talked about boolean
function property testing so what is
boolean function property testing it is
at least to talk about boolean functions
just remind everybody of property of
boolean functions is just another word
for a class of boolean functions mean
function property testing the types of
classes we typically consider a very
similar to the types of classes were
concerned with in computational
complexity classes like when degree
polynomials have spaces monotone
functions simple moving circuits so on
and so forth so a testing algorithm
again this is probably familiar to
everyone over Q be quick it's just a
randomized algorithm which gets to make
blackbox queries to an unknown boolean
function which is completely arbitrary
okay so there's an arbitrary unknown F
the tester can you know give an X get
back f of X and the point of the testing
algorithm is to eventually output either
yes or no depending on whether or not it
thinks the function is in the class or
not okay so to make this a little bit
more precise I'll start by talking about
the standard property testing model
which is kind of a uniform distribution
model and go from there to the model we
really care about this distribution free
model so in the uniform distribution
setting a testing algorithm what is it
supposed to do in order to succeed well
if the function is sort of inside the
green oval meaning that it's a function
in the class it should output yes with
high probability and if the function is
far from every function in the class
it's sort of an outside the outer red
oval event it should output no with high
probability so again these are
randomized algorithms okay and kind of a
crucial thing is that we measured the
distance what do we mean by the distance
between F and G well the distance in the
standard model is just uniform
distribution what fraction of inputs in
the bouillon cube do F and G disagree on
okay and as I'm sure we're all familiar
the main concern and this sort of a
property testing world is information
theoretic upper and lower bounds on the
number of queries we need to
successfully solve this problem and the
gold standard kind of we want to have
algorithms where the
complexity ideally is completely
independent of the number of variables
okay so just kind of basic background on
property testing so there's been quite a
bit of work over the years on algorithms
for testing different classes of boolean
functions I'm not going to go through
this list in any kind of detail the
particular class that I'll be talking
about is this class of k1 t'as so I'm
sure we're all familiar with this a
boolean function on n variables is a K
hooda if it actually depends on only K
variables so there's kind of a hidden
subset of K out of the N variables that
matter and you should think of K as
being independent of n it's a constant
like a hundred or something ok so
there's been quite a bit of work over
the years on testing que juntos it's
probably the best studied class and in
property testing and it kind of is
hidden even in some of the results up
here so results on half-spaces this last
bullet these these are based heavily on
kayo into testing out rooms ok so we'd
like to understand the complexity of
this problem and in fact we do
understand the complexity of K home to
testing very well so if we consider
general algorithms which are allowed to
be adaptive basically K over epsilon or
at least for constant epsilon more or
less linear and k number of queries is
necessary and sufficient for doing this
k12 problem ok and even if we want to
sort of slice the onion finer and think
about non adaptive algorithms we also
understand they're you know with quite a
bit of precision the number of queries
we need in order for non adaptive
algorithms to solve this testing problem
this is
people in the audience Eric and Liang
among others so we seem to know
everything what does this talk about
well k Gupta testing is well understood
in the standard model okay but you can
extend sort of the natural standard
property testing model and I think
there's good reason for thinking about
kind of distribution free extensions to
the standard property testing model so I
don't want to spend too much time on
this motivation but I think you could
really think of Quinta testing is
potentially a useful kind of data
analysis primitive I don't know if
anybody wandered in from the other
semester at Simons if you did you can
run out screaming anytime you like but
you know if in some sense I think of
whom to like a function is a point if
it's a phenomenon that depends on like a
very small number of causes you might
want to know in the real world is this
phenomenon is it complex is that many
causes or few causes but if you want to
sort of put the standard into testing
model into a real-world data analysis
scenario it only matches up well if your
data is sort of uniform over the boolean
hypercube because this is how we think
of distance and probably in most
settings real-world data doesn't isn't
distributed like this so it's natural to
hope for a more general notion where we
aren't tied to the uniform distribution
and that's exactly this distribution
free Hunta testing models so let me
contrast this distribution free model
with the standard model it's quite
similar but there are two kind of
essential differences the key
differences there's now an unknown
distribution D completely arbitrary the
testing algorithm doesn't know it it
could be anything okay and that's the
distribution with respect to which we
think about as kind of a distance
measure for boolean functions we now
look for the distance between F and G
what is the mass that's on the symmetric
difference with respect to that
distribution so this is sort of our
notion of an interesting distribution
now and of course if that's the
interesting distribution we'd better
somehow let the testing algorithm get
some information about it so as before
the tester can make blackbox queries it
has a blackbox Oracle but we also assume
that the tester can make draws from this
distribution so it can push a button and
get a sample from this distribution and
then of course it can query the function
on this point if it's interested and so
on and so forth so it has some access to
this unknown arbitrary distribution and
now it's supposed to tell whether F is
in the class versus Epsilon far from the
class with respect to this district
is the framework make sense the blowing
softly getting independent Dwarfs know
if you could if you could get
arbitrarily everything costs one penny
or I guess in today's Rover $1 for okay
so just a little bit of background
people have studied distribution free
testing for a kind of a modest number of
classes of functions and the takeaway
message I don't want to spend too much
time on this is that for the classes
that were sort of studied today
distribution free testing looks a lot
harder than standard testing so for
various classes where we have a kind of
gold standard query complexity
completely independent of n in the
uniform distribution setting the query
complexities were known to be polynomial
in n in the distribution free setting
and you can also have these kind of
exponential gaps as for monotone
functions and so on
there's the distribution free testing is
certainly at least as hard as standard
testing because one possibilities that
the unknown distribution is just the
uniform distribution so kind of the goal
which worth with which we went into this
work was to understand K hooda testing
right this hood to testing problem which
has been so well studied in the uniform
case well what happens in the
distribution free model or hood is easy
to test are they hard to test and we
have more or less a complete answer so
as I'll tell you we showed that the
Hunta testing for non adaptive
algorithms is sort of hard but it turns
out to be quite easy we were surprised
by how easy it is for adaptive
algorithms they were very efficient
distribution free adaptive when two
testers so let me tell you about the
results in a bit more detail this is not
a new result just as kind of a simple
combination of previously known results
it can be shown that the class of que
juntos can be tested in this
distribution free setting by a non
adaptive algorithm okay but the query
complexity is exponential in K 2 to the
K so on the one hand grade it's
independent of n that's kind of an
important thing to know on the other
hand it's exponential in K and we'd like
to have a more refined understanding
right do we really need this exponential
in K or no so the first result there is
a lower bound in this talk is a lower
bound for non adaptive distribution free
testers the test even to some very
coarse yeah
this explained individual oh you take
the fact that winters have self
correctors you take the fact that
there's a uniform distribution tester
for hunters a two line argument gives
you this theorem good so the takeaway
message from the bottom line which is
which is a new result is that the the
simple kind of combination of these
previous results is essentially best
possible if you want to be non adaptive
non adaptive distribution free testers
need an exponential in K number of
question I have to think about it
yeah I'll explain exactly what I mean by
non adaptive a little later yeah yeah
okay so that's the lower bound for non
adaptive algorithms the upper bound says
that hey out of tivity actually buys you
an exponential improvement so it turns
out that there's an adaptive test there
it's even one-sided it only makes false
positive I guess mistakes for false
negative mistakes I can never remember
which is which for K hunters which is
almost as efficient as the distribution
free case and the distribution in the
uniform case in the uniform case you
know K of R epsilon is possible in
distribution free we can do K squared
over epsilon okay so pretty close and
this is again kind of dissimilar to
these other classes and we looked at
earlier where we had either constant
versus polynomial in N or apollyon
versus exponential in n here it's a
polynomial relationship between
distribution free and uniform
distribution so that's it thank you very
much no I'll go a little longer yeah
yeah that's a great question I have
never seen anything like that I don't
think it's likely that there is
something like that because like with
property testing it's not the case that
if I have this class and then I have a
larger class that the larger class is
necessarily easier or harder to test in
the smaller class as you grow a class it
can get easier than harder than easier
than harder like the empty class is easy
to test the class of all functions is
easy to test things go up and down in
the middle in different ways so I don't
know of any kind of dimension like that
capturing it yeah okay yeah so when the
rest of the talk I do some time left
I'll say a little bit to give you kind
of an intuition for where the lower
bound comes from but I'll probably spend
most of the time on the upper bound
sketching some of the ideas behind how
we can get a poly K query algorithm okay
so let me tell you a little bit about
the lower bound
most of what I want to accomplish here
is just to tell you the construction
because I think given the construction
you sort of look at it you say yeah
probably there's a lower bound to be
proved there so the technique for
proving this non adaptive testing lower
bound is a very standard once we go
through Yao's minimax principle no
usually if you're familiar with this
line of work you know for the min/max
principle you say okay I just have to
prove a lower bound over deterministic
algorithms so the job of the guy who's
proving the lower bound is to come up
with the distribution over yes instances
and a distribution of over no instances
that's also our job but in this
framework since it's this distribution
free set up the yes instances this
distribution this yes distribution is
going to be a distribution over
distribution over 0 1 to the N in comma
boolean function pairs but that's what
this distribution do yes is over and
Deno is also over distribution function
pairs and we have to show that
algorithms that make 2 to the K over 3
many queries deterministic algorithms
can't tell whether the distribution
function pair was a yes guy or no guy
okay so that's kind of our job okay
so let me try to tell you about this yes
case in this no case the yes
distribution over distribution function
pairs I'll start by telling you about
the distribution which is extremely
simple to generate the distribution
part of the distribution function pair
drawn from des I you know firmly
randomly pick two to the K log endpoints
somewhat more than 2 to the K points
okay
and I make my distribution uniform over
those points so this is just a bunch of
black dots here these two to the K log n
points the function part of the
distribution function pair is exactly
what you'd expect you pick a random K
Hunta so you choose K variables
uniformly at random given those the
identity of those K variables right
there's two to the K possible settings
for those variables the picture is
supposed to illustrate kind of the
different possible settings of the
relevant variables we think of these as
sections and to which the boolean cube
has been chopped up and we just pick a
random function over those so we just
color each section toss a coin and color
it block away okay so this is the
distribution function case and the
distribution function pair in the yes
case it's obvious that these are all yes
functions they're all kihon does my
construction for the no case supposed to
look similar but it's different in
crucial ways so the distribution is
exactly the same we picked two to the K
log and random points the distribution
is uniform over those points okay the
function is sort of where the action is
happening we do the same thing as before
we pick K variables at random we color
the sections at random but there's a
twist within each section in a Hamming
ball around the point where the
probability distribution is supported we
toss a fresh coin and we color all those
points according to the fresh coin toss
okay so again like these are big Hamming
balls their radius is point four and
let's say but we only sort of have this
Hamming ball restricted to this section
this having all the hemming balls are
just restricted section by section by
section okay so this is the note
construction and I'm not gonna give a
proof but I do need to at least explain
to Emanuele in to everyone else what is
even meant by a non adaptive algorithm
okay so what does a non adaptive
algorithm in the setting well the fair
way to define it is that first the
algorithm gets to press the distribution
button two to the K over three times
it sees the points that came from the
distribution then it gets to make two to
the K over three again let's say
non-adaptive queries so these queries
can depend on what it saw when it made
its draws from the distribution but it
can't choose you know the third query
point may
and the answers that it was given in
response to the first and second query
points okay so does this explain what's
my pent-up difficut okay good so that's
a non adaptive algorithm we kind of have
to show that you know the data we get in
the first part doesn't help these two to
the K over three many samples aren't
informative and the two to the K over 3
menu non adaptive queries also don't
help us so it's kind of easy to see that
the samples are useless right what are
you going to see in the yes case when
you make two to the K over three many
draws from the distribution well
birthday paradox you'll see a different
point in every section with high
probability and that's exactly what
you'll see in the no case I don't know
if you can see these are like red dots
right across the sections red dots
spread across the section and the color
of each dot is independent uniform
random the samples they just look
exactly the same
okay so that was no good what about the
queries this is of course the more
interesting part maybe not adaptive
query is somehow I can figure something
out okay so what can on adaptive queries
do well they can't do much I'm not going
to prove that but let me just try to
give some intuition in this one slide
intuitively if you want to tell that
you're in the know case as opposed to
the yes case what you need to do is you
need to be able to come up with two
inputs two points could be anywhere in
the section that are labeled differently
if you don't succeed in doing that then
you're really seeing the same thing in
the yes case in the no case right this
is the way in which the yes case and the
no case differ okay so how can you try
to come up with two points in the same
section that are labeled differently
well probably are going to start with
one of your sample points which is like
this red point here and what are you
going to do very much not a proof but
intuitively I think the only thing you
can do is you can flip some number of
bits go away from this point and it's
sort of a lose-lose situation suppose
you flip a lot of coordinates suppose
you flip more than n over K many
coordinates right well by flipping you
know 1 over K fraction of coordinates
you're gonna wander out of the section
probably and so that's not doing you any
good if you flip you know a lot more
than n over K many coordinates you're
probably gonna end up at like this green
point or this blue point you'll wander
out of the section and you won't be
accomplishing your goal of finding a
differently colored point in the same
section on the other hand if you don't
flip too many bits if you flipped less
than n over K bits maybe you will stay
in the same section but remember these
Hamming balls are of radius point four n
really big so you didn't flip enough
bits to get out of the Hamming ball
you're just gonna see another point of
the same color because we're in the same
in the same spot okay
so this is the intuition which underlies
the long bit lower bound you can make it
precise and prove a 2 to the N 2 to the
K over 3 lower bound for non adaptive
algorithms does it make sense at some
intuitive level good ok good so I guess
I still have some time left and the rest
of the talk I'll say a little bit about
the adaptive algorithm so again to
remind you this is going to be an
algorithm we know it has to be adaptive
by the lower bound we've just seen which
will succeed in you know solving this
epsilon testing problem with polynomial
number of queries basically K squared
many queries okay so we somehow have to
use that apptivity how are we going to
do it
what's an adaptive algorithm well the
all-time great adaptive algorithm in my
mind is probably binary search right you
see what happened you choose your next
step so on and so forth and indeed this
uniform distribution hoody tester of
Eric bleh is the kind of the gold
standard for the best query complexity
uses binary search and a very simple but
very conceptually very simple of a very
very effective way so let me sketch for
you a simplified version of Eric's
uniform distribution testing algorithm
remember the real tester that the result
of this paper is a K over epsilon query
algorithm independent Devan but what I
want to sketch for you is a much worse
algorithm an algorithm which also has a
log n factor in the query complexity
okay and it's not too hard to imagine
how this would go it's probably going to
do some kind of binary search that's
exactly what it does essentially this
let me just yeah
this simplified version of the algorithm
but that I'll tell you about I think I
think of it as the way it works is it
repeats
say a hundred over a hundred K over
epsilon many attempts to find a new
relevant variable okay if it succeeds in
finding a new relevant variable k plus 1
times then it knows that it's not
dealing with a hundo because it's found
k plus 1 many relevant variables on the
other hand intuitively if I made a
hundred k over epsilon many attempts to
find k plus 1 relevant variables and I
didn't succeed in finding them it
hopefully seems intuitive to probably
the function is epsilon close to not
having k plus 1 relevant variable
to being a hunter okay so this is
exactly how we should think of the
algorithm is working it repeatedly tries
to grow by one a set of variables that
are known to be relevant how does it
grow by one a set of known to be
relevant variables well it does it in a
very natural way you pick a random point
X okay and you re randomized the
coordinates which are the ones in
question the ones outside this set of
known to be relevant variables to get a
new point Y you know you didn't change
any of the relevant variables because
you only reran demise the coordinates
outside the set are of relevant
variables and you query these two points
maybe they disagree if they disagree
you're in luck do binary search and find
a new relevant coordinate okay so I felt
compelled to add this next slide I think
we've all seen by Anna research so I
don't know that there's a great deal of
point to it but maybe just as kind of an
illustration for the set of variables
that we you know know to be relevant so
far are 1 2 & 3 you draw your string X
and then when you're drawing your next
stream Y you freeze those coordinates
Yuri randomize all the other coordinates
you hope that actually the function has
different values on those two inputs and
if so you do the binary search we all
know how to do binary loops we all know
how to do binary search right and it's
gonna take of course log n queries to
find the relevant variable with that
binary search okay so hopefully it's
clear why this algorithm has a query
complexity like K log N and we sort of
do the whole thing caver Epsilon many
times in our temp so that's the overall
query complexity for the algorithm
epsilon is less than 1 over 2 to the K
it works if it doesn't if it's not then
it's off the hook so yeah yeah yeah
crazy setting seems very difficult to
fix those first two bits and make
parties better relevant yeah I didn't
say this works in the distribution free
setting this is the warm-up to the
uniform distribution algorithm so yeah
that's what we have to overcome yeah
yeah I'll hopefully get there right so
just a quick word because it's it is
relevant for our work as well how does
bleh do better than this why does he not
have a login in his query complexity
well he works with blocks of variables
instead of single variables you sort of
have to never get your hands dirty and
even identify a single variable you need
log and bits of information to identify
one variable you don't want to make log
n queries so he randomly partitions the
variables into blocks does binary search
sort of block wise instead of variable
wise and is he able to put it all
together and get a query complexity
independent Devan his analysis heavily
goes through this kind of Ephron Stein
or Fourier decomposition it like
crucially relies on product space
structure and his algorithm works for
any product distribution in fact but
it's like Russell is suggesting it's
unclear it was unclear to us for quite a
while what to do in the distribution
free setting ok so that's kind of a
challenge turns out that if you're
willing to lower your standards which we
thought we were for some time you can
get away with a very very simple variant
to be algorithm I just showed you if
you're willing to have a login in your
query complexity ok then really a
one-line of the five word change of the
simple algorithm works and the analysis
is quite simple ok the only change is
that you do exactly the way you did it
before it's just that you draw that
first string X from the distribution D
instead of from the uniform distribution
which is very natural ok it wouldn't
really make sense to reran demise why
according to distribution D right to try
to find that other string what you do
for Y is you uniformly again just as
before this is highlighted in red
because it's important for what's coming
up at this the the red italics part is
exactly the same as the uniform
algorithm the change is that you draw X
from distribution D and then you do
everything as before but this is the key
thing you have to be able to uniformly
re randomize all the coordinates outside
that set of relevant variables ok and if
you can do that then there's a kind of a
simple structural result and it just
goes through yeah
yeah you could be misled yes this is
future work which I hope Clement and and
Eric will will do is to extend our
results to the tolerance setting but
none of our results are for that
settings for this algorithm yeah the
number of draws from the distribution
you're right you only need those 4x so
that would be like 100 K over epsilon
the queries would be for the Y part this
is for what no they're the announced
that there's no Fourier if there's no 4e
in the talk yeah it's really it's a very
simple analysis though it's it's not
hard at all okay so if we were willing
to lower our standards and have this log
independence we'd be done but you know
let's let's try to do a little bit more
so how are we gonna get rid of the login
well intuitively we kind of know we can
never touch a single variable right
it'll take us login queries login bits
of information to learn the name of a
variable that's that's a road we can't
go down so somehow we have to also be
working over blocks we feel instead of
single variables okay so that's
something we want to do and we saw in
the simple algorithm and the one from
the last slide the key thing is to be
able to uniformly re randomize these
coordinates right outside the set of
relevant variables whatever that set of
sort of known to be relevant variables
are but it's weird because we don't know
what this set is certainly we've never
seen and I can't even figure out the
name with a single variable unless I
make login query so it feels a little
bit like a chicken and egg thing how am
I going to re randomize these
coordinates outside that set without
knowing what what is in that set okay so
we'll see that that's exactly what we
are able to do and being able to do that
sort of is the key to the result let me
tell you a little bit about the set up
for the algorithm kind of once you have
in mind what you want to sort of
maintain it's not that bad so the
algorithm we're gonna think of it as
maintaining a list of relevant blocks
destroyed blocks this is like the
variables 1 through n this block b1 is
over here this other block b2 is over
here so on and so forth okay so we're
gonna maintain these blocks
for each block we're gonna keep two
strings an X string the Y string and
these are kind of the strings which
witness the fact that the block has a
relevant variable so if you look at x1
and y1 they match everywhere except on
this block and this block they're
different ok so there's like a common
assignment outside the block I call that
W I for X I and y I okay and you know f
of X does is different from F of Y so
this kind of the existence of these
strings x and y where the function
differs and they differ only within this
block tells me there's a relevant
variable in that block okay and kind of
a key assumption which took us a long
time to get to is that we want to assume
we'll see in a minute how it makes our
life much easier to assume that for each
one of these blocks if I restrict the
function and kind of the correct way
outside the block and reduce it to just
a function over the variables in this
block let me for the moment assume that
that function is actually close to a 100
okay to like you know just a single
literal function somewhere one of these
literals in here so the picture is
supposed to capture this that you know I
don't know if you can see within this
block I have like one bold-faced
variable because fixing all the other
variables you know as according to X 2
and Y 2
it's a one hook to here on this bit
fixing all the other variables outside
here it's a one who do I miss on this
bold of it this is what we want to
assume that we've got so far ok some
blocks and this kind of x and y info and
it's like a hood a one point over B 1 a
one hood two over B 2 so what's it in ok
good good great so this is just
repeating what I just said that this is
what the algorithm holds on to now let
me define this set are the set of sort
of known to be relevant variables I
don't know what that set is but the the
right way to think of this set is is
it's that collection of who into
variables so it's like these bold
variables from the last slide this would
be one of the variables whatever
coordinate this is this would be another
variable whatever coordinate this is and
so on that's like the set of relevant
variables ok the key to the success of
our algorithm is the fact that actually
we can uniformly reran demise the
coordinates outside that set even though
we don't know what that set of relevant
variables
okay so in the next slide I'll show you
how we do that and then hopefully it'll
become clear how the whole thing works
so what do I want to argue I want to
argue that I don't know what this v1 is
this one Hunter variable in this block I
don't know what this v2 is this one
hooked a variable in this block but I
can still come up with a uniform random
subset of the complement of the set v1
and v2 and uniform random subsets of the
complement is the same thing as being
able to rent three randomized the
variables outside that set so how do I
do it well you know let me attack it one
block at a time for the first block I'll
randomly split the block into two pieces
okay and I just need to be able to tell
now which block is the relevant variable
in and that's easy to do right the
function restricting to this block is
basically a one who does so I flipped
this half I flipped the compliment I see
which time it changed okay so I can tell
which piece do you want is it a when I
split b1 into two pieces I can tell
which piece v2 is in and if I just put
together sort of this information along
with the uniform random subset of the
rest of the stuff I'll get a uniform
random subset of everything but v1 and
v2
right so why you know well if I take a
uniform random subset of everything
that's not in the block it's a random
subset of the white stuff let's think
about the first block if I randomly
split b1 into two pieces and I can
figure out which of those pieces doesn't
have v1 and I take it well that's
exactly a uniform random subset of
everything in block one except for
variable one okay you have the same
thing for block two Union everything
together and you've got exactly a
uniform random subset of everything but
v1 and v2
okay so we're able to do this key step
of reran demising uniformly all the
coordinates outside the set of relevant
variables even though we don't know what
that set is so I owe you something right
we made this assumption which was that
each restricted function each sort of
wave restricting the function to block 1
to block 2 is close to a 100 is close to
a 100 over block 1 close to a 100 over
block 2 so on and so forth well we use
the one hunter District uniform
distribution testing algorithm and I
just restrict all the variables outside
the block according to the
setting shared by X&Y and I run the
uniform distribution one hunter tester
on the block what can happen one of two
things can happen
maybe the tester tells me you know
congratulations you are a one hunter
over that block if that happens that's
great that's what I wanted the other
possibility is that the you know uniform
distribution one hunter tester rejects
it says you know you're not close to a
100 block but if you look at the way the
uniform distribution 100 tester works
when it rejects it kind of rejects with
a certificate it rejects because it
found two relevant blocks it sort of
came up with two blocks where it knows
there's a relevant variable in each one
so in this case the output of the one
who detest her lets us make progress it
splits what was previously a block that
I knew had one relevant variable into
two blocks each of which has one
relevant variable so I've made progress
toward my sort of overall goal of coming
up with k plus 1 blocks each of which
has a relevant variable if I can do that
I know it's not a 100 it's not a Kate
Hunt and I'm done
okay so the algorithm on the next slide
is probably not worth going over in
detail you just combine these sort of
intuitions in the obvious way and you're
able you're able to get the overall
tester so I just want to close by
talking about a little bit of possible
directions that I think would be
interesting for future work I'm just
reminding you of the results here it's
this algorithm that we just sketched
with the poly K over epsilon query
complexity using this binary search idea
and the lower bound for non adaptive
algorithms in terms of future work one
goal is obviously it would be nice to
get sharp bound so currently we're a
little bit off between distribution free
and uniform distribution in the uniform
distribution case we have basically K
over epsilon query algorithms and here
for arbitrary distributions we seem to
need K squared instead of K query so
it'd be nice to close that gap maybe a
more interesting goal is to try to
extend the result in the sorts of ways
that you guys addressed already with
questions it would be nice to understand
something about whether we can make this
distribution free test or tolerant we
don't really know very much about making
uniform distribution testers tolerant we
don't know as much as we would like
there are other variants of testing
models if you're sort of motivated by
making it potentially practically useful
such as active testings
Oh base testing and so on so some
directions for future work that's it
Thank You Keith the number of blocks so
the algorithm builds this up initially
starts with like yeah I guess maybe that
whole set of n variables is one block or
something built it builds it as it goes
if it ever has if it ever reaches K plus
1 that's when it stops and says you're a
you're not a K current uh and if it
tries 100 K over epsilon many times to
build it up to k plus 1 and it didn't
get there within a hundred K over
epsilon rise then it says no you're
you're not a
if you see the mention of K hunters I
guess it's just this embarrassing I'm on
tape I'm teaching a learning theory
course this semester I'm probably gonna
give this as a homework problem next
week or something I think it's okay
right yeah two to the K the vc-dimension
is as far as I know kind of coming back
to Ramirez question I don't know that it
has any relevance for uniform
distribution property testing or a
distribution free property testing it's
a learning theoretic parameter it tells
us what the query complexity or the
sample complexity of learning but I
don't think it yeah I've had the same
dreams about trying to sort of connect
these things but the BCD met I mean one
way to see it is the VC dimension is no
notion of distribution tied to it like
you could you could have a concept class
which has large VC dimension but it's
because of a very small set of examples
which really have nothing to do with
whether the function is globally like in
the class or far from the class right so
I don't think it's I don't think there's
a connection
sorry you might have already said it but
if the one who does hester rejects this
just means that the block this could use
it to pick up blockers close or give to
use certificate that those two blocks
that all known are far away from one
into under the uniform of the
distribution
exactly so how do you convert this to
progress in the distribution as long as
your function is not a que canta
distribution free tester can reject
safely right so yeah so that's that's
good enough evidence even for even for
the distance with respect to D if you
know that it's not a 100 if you know
that the app function is not a Quixote
you can reject in you're off the hook
yes this is not an obvious fact that
ways algorithm gives you the certificate
but it take my word for it it does yeah
adapted wrongs to use I guess it's like
in the uniform case just put binary
search there is the way to search by
going to that final activity
to kill the three to get to the 17 oh
yeah
probably probably instead of K squared
over epsilon rounds about activity I
think just K over epsilon I think be
enough for if you look at how the
algorithm really works how many rounds
of an activity but if if someone asking
that question I'm saying she does climb
up that questions he would know this
kind of thing so yeah you could look at
the algorithm to determine I think would
be polynomial in case early
[Applause]